whatever it's not 100 none of them are
yeah it didn't work the condom broke or
her thing it just she's the one is a
fluke the thing didn't work okay and
then fine okay yeah but so but
essentially in a one-night stand you're
saying she should get paid out
yeah okay go ahead
that was a long trip sorry
um in a one night stand i think no i
sorry
if you want if you want to make that
difference so do you think men should be
able to have a financial abortion since
we can have an abortion
i think if you want to do the special
law you can but it's the that's the
general question glenn yeah i think i
want to use the whole
i mean yeah i mean
yeah okay yeah you've got equal rights
right yeah at the end of the day because
i personally wouldn't want to have an
abortion
so but like yeah yeah in the name of
equality yeah okay what about you
um can we just define financial abortion
again please okay so
if you get pregnant
you're keeping the kid
he says you know what i i didn't mean to
get you pregnant i want nothing to do
with this kid he can sign off financial
rights
and parental rights yes yeah i think
i'll say the opposite um
to what rue said which is i think if
it's a one-night stand
i think he has every right to do that
just because yeah they're both
consenting adults but
as a woman you have more to lose
going into the situation so you should
be more
cautious and you know
be responsible and if it happens then he
has the right to say no i don't want to
be involved because that's what it was
at the time and that's what it is but if
you're in a relationship
and
you know this one time we've done it
and we've gotten pregnant when we've
done it many times before and i haven't
then
i don't think he should have the right
to
bail out of it because we were doing it
before the only difference is i've
gotten pregnant now so
you should just be responsible for it
just like i am did you did you know did
you know there are entire reddit threads
of women talking to each other trying to
figure out how to trap a guy that
they're dating
yeah
there are men that talk about how women
will steal condoms yeah and so so the
whole point and it's okay a lot of
people have never thought about it like
this is your incentive if you're paying
out bad behavior
you're paying women to make bad choices
instead of saying you made this choice
you deal with the consequences
i mean it also happens the other way
around i feel like not just women do
that in terms of condoms guys also
stealth so like take off their condoms
midway and you don't if you're not
really in your sixth sense
you could also get pregnant so women are
cases
women can actually have a man brought up
on grape charges if they take the call
yes
yeah so men have a consequence for that
women
don't get me wrong like i obviously
believe
women are responsible for
their wombs like that's why i'm not
active
like i'm responsible for it yes like
when i want to get pregnant that's my
decision right yeah i understand the
the consequences and all that stuff
it's just that you know again
my my exception is a why night stand
you know in society as a man
what the consequences are you know you
have the woman you know
the woman that's the thing though that's
the thing so why don't they both deal
with the car you're both playing russian
roulette right in that situation because
you're strangers yeah you know i i've
never had a situation where people just
go to a club they meet up they want to
have sex and then they go are you
pro-life for pro-choice
if something happens here if your
contraception doesn't work
like that's the thing though
but if you okay okay we're done with the
club i i i'm feeling you i want a
physical relationship
then maybe we can have a small
discussion about things if you're
responsible but after after that i can
understand the situation
why you'd want a financial abortion
whatever so why is she entitled to child
support in a one-night stand why does
she deserve it
in a one-eyed stand yeah because you
said
again i don't think she deserves it i
don't i don't think they so she would
get it so therefore she would deserve it
because that's how the system is i'm
just basing it on how things are no but
i asked you how you would make it and
that's what you said so i i wouldn't say
i wouldn't say yeah i was just basing
like on how it is like yeah of course
pay for it you're both irresponsible
you're both strangers so now you're
ending up having to raise a child
straight right so you would agree then
that he should be able to have a
financial abortion yeah he doesn't have
to pay childcare yeah i don't think
she's entitled to it she was being
irresponsible in in in most parts of the
world you wouldn't be getting that okay
okay can i pose a scenario because a lot
of the ladies you said you said that in
a one-night stand
um
he can have a financial abortion whilst
in a relationship he shouldn't do you
also agree that in a woman's scenario if
in your particular ideal scenario if a
woman is in a relationship with a man
and she gets pregnant but she wants to
abort but he wants to keep it would you
allow him to keep
force her not to have an abortion and
keep the baby because he wants to keep
it
it's a complicated one but i would say
you are entitled you are entitled to be
a father i think it would depend on the
woman's reason for wanting the abortion
in that circumstance just based on i
think it's very sticky but i think it's
the woman's reason if she's like oh i'm
too young to have a child then that
that's not good
but what i've noticed is you you can you
can say a woman
you said in a one-night stand he can
have a financial
abortion that's fine but in a
relationship he has to then take the
responsibility but yet at the same time
that woman still has even in a
relationship the option to abort so
you're not taking away the woman's right
to a board but you're taking his right
away from having a financial abortion i
think it's wrong to
take away his right to be a father if he
wants to be have the baby
and let him raise the baby but that's
what i mean would you say that if
if a man says i want to keep the baby
could you just carry you know take the
pregnancy to full term yeah and let me
take care of it yeah would you say that
the woman should then at that point not
have the right to abort
um yeah i guess so yeah yeah
okay that's at least for clarity that's
a concern
the point of the abortion is to get rid
of the baby so there's a second means of
doing it without killing the baby
get rid of it
and still pay child support sorry
what oh yeah yeah yeah she's still
playing again yeah
you didn't want yeah so would the woman
now pay child support to their managers
the way it's actually set up is based on
who's taking care of the child full term
and who has the most money if she has
more money i don't know if if he's
taking if i had more money than you but
you had the child for me and you gave me
the child would you pay me child support
if you make it it's an exception it's
not the role most
most men don't win in those cases yeah
but if you wanted to take care of the
baby that means you're taking care of
the child full term that means the woman
would be paying child support because
you you're the carer you would need
support
so actually if she gave birth to the
baby and gave it to you she would have
to pay child support
yeah
and that's why men don't win in most
court cases
and that's why they bought them
it's like i know if you want me to give
that baby to you i'd be paying for it
because you'll be the main carer yeah
i think women abort them actually
because they're hypergamous
they want a guy that makes more women
one out of three babies um that are
aborted up from women that make over
forty seven thousand dollars per year
one out of three where only only
eight percent of um babies below the
poverty line are aborted